what can I get you I want to get drunk
but I don't want to get fat
I have CrossFit in the morning hey man
I'm just happy to be here you know wings
nachos playoff games it's all good
if I could wear sandals somewhere
believe me I will I went to a liberal
arts college I listened to all my music
on vinyl and wherever we go for dinner
it's never as good as this other place I
know
Spring Break junior year was the
greatest five days and my whole life I
can look for months of chips and salsa
and I am down to go to Applebee's
whenever I own my own tuxedo and love to
mentioning casual conversation I pretend
to like foreign films and will probably
interrupt you to correct your grammar
I've been a bridesmaid five times in the
past year alone my friends constantly
asked me if I'm okay sometimes I smile
like I'm dead inside
mm-hmm I came here tonight with my BFF
and we are not messing around we are
here to get so drunk yeah I love you at
each other and take a million selfies
from above in the bathroom do not hit on
us okay hit on us I might be a sociopath
there are no colors in my wardrobe and I
have one of those laughs that stops on a
dime I'm someone's little sister I love
musical theater and the show Scrubs I
sell my own dresses I try not to take
myself too seriously
I own one really nice pair of shoes and
if I have to stand in line to get in
someplace I won't go I think I'm better
than you I used to drink Manhattan's
because I went on a Great Gatsby binge
but now I'm super into madman
yeah I've thought about grad school
lately I own a leather jacket that's
worn in a really cool way but I actually
bought it like that I have a favorite
tapas place I will fight you at the drop
of a hat
[Music]